alors macworld en fin de semaine dit
j'ai affaire à la ville de montréal d
abri pour l'hiver pour que les sans abri
peuvent aller se réchauffer les mini
maison si vous voulez et la ville n'a
toujours pas répondu à mon avis ça fait
deux fois anie samson luc ferrandez
bonsoir bonsoir on va écouter la brs
d'abord qui répond pourquoi elle a dit
non et on revient ensuite
j'ai envie de vous dire que ni la ville
ni les organismes communautaires travail
que les personnes en situation
d'itinérance le on aime se dire non
quand on use of the lights et personne
qui aime se dire non mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'en ce moment à
montréal puis moi je peux pas parler des
autres municipalités mai à montréal le
problème spots en l'espace c'est d'avoir
du personnel qualifié des gens qui
peuvent accompagner les personnes en
situation d'itinérance
bon alors s'en est suivi le refus de la
ville sur twitter sur facebook beaucoup
de gens ont dit mais pourquoi à la ville
de montréal refuse de l'aide annie qu'en
pensez vous ben c'est je trouve ça plate
que madame plantes dit non les deux des
deux de l'année dernière et cette année
je pense que celle mérite d'être bien
étudiée il faut l'expliquer oui on a
besoin d'endroits parce qu'il ya déjà on
le dit cette semaine et des itinérants
qui ne veulent pas aller à l'intérieur
des refuges y dorment dehors il y en a
quatre qui sont morts de froid depuis le
début de l'année pour moi c'est
important dit regardons l'ensemble fait
un projet pilote prenons en vain avec un
organisme qui veut dire oui avec un
support qui va avec bien organisés est
ce que le feu est ce que c est ce que
c'est c'est c'est propice pour le feu ou
pas comment c'est fait mais dire non
tout simplement bêtement sans les avoir
vus je trouve sa place parce que des
projets pilotes c'est ce qui nous fait
avancer on peut l'essayer si ça marche
pas on aura le mérite de dire oui on là
ça y est non ça marche pas mais il faut
prendre le temps de les regarder le dos
et je vais revenir après avec des
questions pour vous emmener sur quel ça
veut dire encadré à faire de même et luc
premières impressions
je comprends madame plante je comprends
madame plan je sais que c'est une
réponse difficile de dire non mais il ya
plusieurs précédents j'évoquais tu
t'entoures avec vous a dit que par
exemple les toilettes publiques le
projet pilote de toilettes publiques eux
dans une barrique commence à 2017
rapidement on s'est rendu compte que des
boîtes aux lettres sans supervision
c'est un échec total faut comprendre que
les gens qui sont dans la rue souffrent
souvent de problèmes de santé mentale ce
qui fait d'eux des victimes potentielles
ou parfois des agresseurs potentiels et
ça se produit pour vrai dans la rue des
gens qui font de la taxation de
l'intimidation et de la prostitution
l'injection de drogues lieu de tout dans
les toilettes publiques il y avait de
tout notre république on avait la
confiance
laissez une toilette sans surveillance
c'est paul ne sait pas faire un cadeau
ou aux itinérants même chose avec les
églises avant on ouvrait il y avait une
incurie couvraient leur église vous
remarquerez que la plupart des curés qui
sont pourtant des gens bien intentionnés
ont tous décidé de fermer leur église
parce que c'est passé mille et une
choses les églises dans mon quartier
j'en étais j'allais voir l'écurie door
demander pourquoi c'est une très bonne
question
mais me raconter des histoires
extraordinairement surprenantes comme
par exemple des gens qui faisaient leurs
besoins sur les bancs d'église parce
qu'ils étaient trop intoxiqué pour se
rendre aux toilettes dans juste mettre
un espace par exemple qui voyage qui va
y avoir droit est ce que la personne qui
est plus forte votre château de tanlay
c'est moi qui y va il ya toutes sortes
de choses qu'il faut réfléchir vous vous
dites c'est une fausse bonne idée le
lendemain oui bon année vous dites parce
que évidemment les broues de
commentaires en fin de semaine
l'avc des technocrates qui comprennent
pas la générosité
comment gérer comment vous gérez en à
faire demain faut que jack et john utaka
ban ça prend du monde pour gérer son
année là oui mais on a vu des organismes
centraux aujourd'hui que 10 mois je
serai capable et gérer qu'il faut les
encadrer faux distincts projet pilote
s'est pas c'est pas 12 mois par année
c'est dans le temps où il fait froid
dans le temps ou ans actuellement et
encore des gens qui vont dormir dehors
ce soir il faut choisir la clientèle six
à vingt cabane il y avait vingt
personnes qui vont être suivis qui vont
accepter un protocole entendu koshla
mais tu fais pour rien brûlé sud il ya
comme un il faut l'entendre et un projet
pilote sont les seuils peau
on n'aura jamais la réponse on éveille
body c'est vrai que la ville s'est fait
de fonctionnaires puis on voit jamais
dans un chemin quand on connait pas trop
trop on est comme ça nous autres les
québécois on se dit ah on n'est pas sûr
on n'ira pas parce qu'on connaît pas
mais pourquoi pas de l'essayer moi j'ai
essayé plein de choses dans ma vie il ya
des fois que ça a bien fonctionné dans
mon arrondissement il ya des votes n'a
pas bien été hormis si on laissait et
pau en europe a le mérite de le dire luc
connaissait pas ni vous dire qu'on
essaye mais écoute parce que moi je
pense que la probabilité que ça marche
pas et forte mais par contre c'est vrai
que ça pourrait servir à une certaine
clientèle il ya des gens qui ne veulent
pas donner ça qui est mort au parc des
hauts gradés la falaise coteaux saint
pierre ils refusaient de regagner un
centre pour ces personnes à qui refuse
de gagner 100 dans les soirées ou
extrêmement froid si on est capable de
décider si personnelle de leurs données
à eux ça pourrait être une bonne idée
mais oui il faudra de la cad rick
victoriaville a dit nous moi je vais en
prendre vingt années plus facile à gérer
la boj ans j'en sais rien mais j'avais
pas qu'elle veut des itinérants
victoriaville mais tant mieux si le
maire a le goût de l'essayer ben c'est
peut-être lui le précurseur qui va
pouvoir nous irons la cia fonctionnaires
garder à montréal maintenant vous
devriez l'essayer pu l'essayer sur des
clientèles particulières pas tout le
monde l'homme est ce qu'on voit le soir
les patrouilleurs de police ça envoie on
est avec un organisme communautaire qui
dit moi je m'engage à m'assurer que ce
soit bien utilisé
pourquoi pas le laisser y est ça coûte à
lui gratuit a pas
d'accord a ni pourquoi pas d'essayer
mais en encore en prenant quand même des
indices zew s'est patiemment dans les
paris avant il y avait des espèces de
tuyaux de béton qui servait de lieu de
tunnels où les enfants pouvaient passer
on les autres tous sens le 8 pourquoi
parce que des gens qui faisaient leurs
besoins dedans et que les enfants
étaient mis au grand stade avec des
déjections humaines mais j'aimerais ses
salariés leur avenir elle part que je
voulais déjà 10 points pour revenir aux
étudiants ou des gardiens de parc à
garder wallonie mais on pourrait
peut-être plus loin on parle des
toilettes publiques les calculs
toilettes publiques mais qu est ce qu on
a différents avec nos amis européens ou
américains qui ont des toilettes
publiques dans toutes les grandes villes
les gars qu'on a déjà il peut arriver
des incidents on les enlève tous les
gérer il faut les gérer mais pourquoi on
n'est pas capable en rien les gérer non
non on est capable mais c'est mieux que
son investissement c'est à dire qu il
faut il faut mettre du personnel pour
cet exploit alors il faut faire le choix
de personnel puisse percevoir c'est de
l'argent oui mais voilà merci
et je lance un message eu des gens qui
auraient beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
peut-être qu'ils veulent à aider je
donne les adresses fait des fois c'est
plus à donner mais voici mission old
brewery les numéros de téléphone les
vols d'essai le temps qu'ils font les
courriels ici tu devrais je dire mission
bon accueil maison du père alors vous
les ad il ya ces trois organismes là qui
vont vous ouvrir les bras qui vont dire
oui aux problèmes à tous dans qui peut
aider alors voila merci